[Musique]
on est à berlin on est l'ifa en france
ce qui devrait s'appeler l'ifa c'est la
special edition 2020 alors en fait c'est
pas réellement l'ifa telle qu'on l'a
connue savelli fâche pas si vous le
savez c'est un grand salon tech c'est le
grand salon tech européen de la rentrée
il ya tout le monde tout le monde est là
il ya des stands il ya du monde c'est
gavé sauf qu'aujourd'hui à cause de la
crise du coronavirus eh bien voyez c'est
très calme prend dans la salle de kung
fu va y avoir le lancement effectivement
d'honneur et déjà je peux vous dire que
par rapport à hier
il ya pas mal de chaises qui ont été
enlevés là où je suis il y avait plein
de chaise hier pour voir il y en a
beaucoup moins
il ya un problème de fréquentation et ça
c'est normal lié aux qu'ovide n'y a pas
beaucoup de personnes qui sont venues et
que répondu à l'appel en tout cas de
l'ifa special edition en version 2010
[Musique]
la convenance vient d'avoir lieu il ya
quelques instants avec les nouveaux
produits qui ont été présentés nouveaux
macbook pro il ya des mises à jour des
magic bout 14 et 15 pouces ce qui est
des nouvelles man 2 présenté ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on sorte disciples
n'ont pas qu'on soit pas bien non pas
d'éclairage pas sympa mais tout
simplement qu'avec le masque vous voyez
c'est un petit peu complexe on va
seulement un endroit un peu plus
tranquille tranquillement pour venir en
parler vous dire au final ce que je
pense de ce nouveau magic book pro 2 au
nord au nord a lancé plein de nouveaux
produits aujourd'hui une nouvelle
version professionnelle cette fois-ci de
son magic book beaucoup de succès j'ai
déjà présenté il ya quelques mois on en
reparlera ultérieurement une mise à jour
de son magic book 14 mais également 15
pouces avec un nouveau processeur deux
nouvellement de connecteurs il ya plein
de nouveaux prix dans l'écosystème et
c'est ce qu'on va regarder aujourd'hui
on va commencer par le magic book pro il
s'agit d'un pc avec un écran de 16,1
pouces full view une dalle ip sc du lcd
avec une résolution de 1920 par 1080
grands standards un d'écran qui occupent
90 % de la face avant avec une
colorimétrie 100% srgb et il est
certifié lutter contre la lumière bleue
personnellement le design et j'aime bien
encore plus tendance qu'en plus design
et que ce qu'on avait avec les magic
book 14 et magic book 15 pouces
j'aime bien capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour venir déverrouiller
extrêmement facilement votre ordinateur
on a un châssis en aluminium en un
format qui est assez compact et il est
surtout très fin il fait 4,9 mm pour un
poids total de 1.7 kg il a une seule
couleur c'est le space gré il tourne
sous un amd reason 5 4600 h à six coeurs
et douce raid avec une seule config 16
giga de ram c'est la ddr4 et un ssd de
512 go de stockage
une batterie de 56 ou à tort avec un
chargeur de 65 watts vous permet de
recharger de 0 à 50 % seulement 30
minutes et au nord nous annonce une
autonomie de 11 heures en lecture vidéo
en 1080p et jusqu'à 9 heures de
navigation sur internet où je suis pas
sûr qu'on ait vie pendant neuf heures
sur internet n'ont en tout cas si vous
souhaitez le faire pour faire le test et
bien vous invite à le faire et à me dire
ce que vous pensez bien évidemment en
bas en commentaire on a ainsi un
refroidissement avec un double
ventilateur pour une meilleure
dissipation de la chaleur on a toujours
un très grand trackpad pour
utiliser un clavier qu'elle est en tout
cas très optimisé j'ai déjà testé le
match debout 14 et 15 d'ailleurs je vous
renvoie la pression de vidéo mais bon
celui en tout cas à l'air d'être plutôt
bien à voir si le petit défaut qu'on a
donné du trackpad
lorsqu'on appuyer a disparu oui ou non
qui n'était pas gênant pour
l'utilisation mais y avait un petit
jours donc on regardera ça plus tard
lors du test d'ailleurs vous invite à
dès maintenant à venir vous abonner
s'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça vous saurez tout lorsqu'on
testera le magic book pro il tourne bien
évidemment sur windows 10 et vous pouvez
venir faire du mirroring utiliser votre
smartphone en collectant très facilement
grâce au nfc à la fonction de partage
pour pouvoir utiliser votre smartphone
directement au double automatique donc
ça c'est bien un produit quelques jours
destinée aux étudiants lascive le jeune
aux jeunes actifs c'est le coeur de
cible de honor sur l'ensemble des
produits d'écosystèmes et même si ce
modèle lara le monde professionnel il
aura un bon professionnel parce que plus
de performances que le magic book 14 et
15 mai on s'intéresse toujours une fois
de plus au coeur de cible et au nord
c'est à dire un public jeune et c'est un
pc qui sera dispo à partir du 8
septembre au tarif de 800 99,90 centimes
personnellement je le trouve assez
intéressant j'avais bien aimé le magic
bouquet 14 et le magic book 15
celui là on sent vraiment intéressant on
retrouve vraiment la dn2 honneur dans ce
produit là beaucoup plus jolie beaucoup
plus esthétique que les autres modèles
et je pense qu'ils pourraient aussi
avoir beaucoup de succès mais on aurait
également mis à jour c'est magic bout 14
et magic bout 15 avec un nouveau
processeur c'est un amd raizen 5 4500 us
gravé en 7 nanomètres avec une config 8
gigas de ram plus 512 il ya de stockage
à 749 euros 90 l'idée de au nord par
rapport à ces magic bout qu'on va
apprendre que la question des blessés
pour l'instant
et bien c'est de développer la gamme ils
ont fait très fort avec les magic book
14 matchs et de 15 pouces avec un modèle
professionnel ils vont s'adresser à des
personnes qui veulent un peu plus de
performances sans en avoir trop on n'a
pas non plus une config est absolument
incroyable mais pour venir travailler
sur de la bureautique en gagnant
vraiment en fluidité
vous avez un produit qui est pas mal on
va pas avoir des performances de dingue
mais pour tout ce qui va être travail
bureautique prise de notes email à
internet et compagnie bien vous avez un
produit qui en tout cas semble se tenir
être plutôt bien en voix cette gamme qui
s'élargit et qui s'étoffe chez au nord
c'est la même strate que voyez vous
savez au nord et huawei c'est la même
boîte
concernant le smartphone ils ont toutes
les problématiques des services google
contre car avec les services huawei les
hms et notamment la galerie en catalogue
d'applications c'est relativement
compliqué encore ça met du temps et l'on
telle stratégie 2 1 + 8 plus n 1 étant
le smartphone le coeur de votre
écosystème +8 tous les objets connectés
de la marque que vous avez autour dont
fait partie justement le pc les mondes
connectés et puis plus n y sont tous les
partenaires autour avec lesquels au nord
entre autres au nord et huawei mon
travail
à l'occasion de cette conférence qui a
eu tant de produits présentés et
notamment deux mondes connectés la gs
pro qui est une mode connecté urbaine
également pour le sport en extérieur et
en intérieur avec un grand écran
bancaire plutôt sympa il se peut qu on
la teste ultérieurement on n'a plus de
sens mode d'entraînement et elle coûte
249 euros 90 est en pré commande à
partir du 8 septembre
et il ya également la watch es qui est
vraiment une montre dédié sport celle ci
avec un grand écran c'est plutôt bien
format est vraiment intéressant avec
douze types d'entraînements différent
avec un assistant virtuel au tarif de 99
euros 90 est disponible à partir du 21
septembre prochain il ya également une
tablette au nord-pas de 6 avec un écran
de 10,1 pouces bon on passe rapidement
les montres sont assez sexy j'aime bien
la watch es avec ce grand écran plutôt
pas mal alors ici aujourd'hui par le
nouveau smartphone on est vraiment dans
l'écosystème et puis vous savez au nord
avec ses madigou 15 et 14 pouces avait
eu un vrai grand succès moi j'avais bien
aimé et je pense qu'avec le modèle pro
il se peut qu'ils aient également
beaucoup beaucoup de succès d'ailleurs
dit moi ça pourrait potentiellement vous
intéresser en bas en commentaire qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ce pc au nord
magic book pro qu'est ce que vous pensez
des deux mondes connectés que nous a
présenté au nord également de la
tablette et dites moi si vous pourriez
être tenté par l'un de ses produits
cette conférence de presse a lieu dans
des coalitions qui était vraiment
vraiment vraiment particulière donc
c'était la première fois depuis la crise
du court on a les rues ce qu'on avait un
événement physique sur lequel on pouvait
retrouver beaucoup de journalistes çaa
été délicats ou d'organiser cet
événement j'imagine de la part de l'ifa
également délicat pour les marques
d'être présente de dire de quelle
manière ça va être vraiment eu le
respect des gestes barrières et des
distanciation sociales drass et bien et
très rassurant lorsqu'il ya prise en
main des produits gel à l'entrée
manipulation gêne à la sortie donc une
fois de plus c'est pareil dans le
respect des gestes-barrières qui était
quand même particulier et là je fais une
parenthèse en dehors de honor vraiment
par rapport à l'événement qui a été
livré ce n'était pas en réalité at-elle
qu'on connaît ça je voulais expliquer
mais on était dans autre chose pas
forcément bout
beaucoup beaucoup de monde ce qui est
aussi normal mais je pense - prévu il ya
forcément une crainte de la part des
rédactions d'envoyer leurs journalistes
une crainte des personnes d'être
présente également et ça s'entend
complètement ce que ça montre en tout
cas c'est qu'il faudra beaucoup de temps
avant que des événements physique
regroupant beaucoup de monde de
différentes nationalités sur des gros
lancement tel qu'on a pu les connaître
et bien faudra beaucoup de temps avant
que ces événements puissent à nouveau
avoir lieu
il va falloir s'habituer à vivre
différemment dans un métier comme celui
là pendant un bon moment en tout cas ça
a été un expérience un peu particulière
je voulais vraiment venir à sète il va
pouvoir quelle manière est ce qu'ils
allaient réussir à aborder le problème
du coc vide ils l'ont fait plutôt bien
je pense que c'était pas simple pour les
marques présentes devenir pitcher qui
représentait des produits devant une
assemblée un petit peu éparses et il ya
eu beaucoup de marques qu'ils l'ont fait
à distance
c'est un exercice compliqué je pense
pour l'ifa pour les marques et également
pour les journalistes ont de quoi
c'était très cool de pouvoir vous y
venez partager ça avec vous on reparlera
ultérieurement des produits du au nord
en attendant d'ici là j'espère que vous
allez bien portez vous bien que je vous
renvoie comme d'habitude beaucoup
d'amour pour le soin de vous ciao ciao
ciao
[Musique]